lourdes inició un negocio de producción
de cosméticos elaborados con
ingredientes naturales ella desea
promover sus productos distribuyendo
bolsas con muestras en su vecindario
ella ha calculado que le toma dos
minutos preparar cada bolsa cuántas
horas si mira aquí es muy importante
pensar en horas le tomará preparar mil
200 bolsas de muestras si le pide a
siete amigos que le ayuden vamos a
empezar calculando cuánto le tomaría a
ella sola preparar las mil 200 bolsas de
muestras y nos están diciendo que a ella
le toma dos minutos preparar cada bolsa
esto es dos minutos por bolsa
después si a este dato lo multiplicamos
por las 1200 bolsas
1200 x 2 es 2400
y nos quedan minutos es decir
a lourdes le toma 2400 minutos preparar
las 1200 bolsas y bien habrá que ser
cuidadosos porque uno podría pensar si
divido este dato en 37 ya tengo la
respuesta pero en total son 8 personas
las que van a realizar el trabajo
lourdes y sus 7 amigos es decir 8
estamos pensando que más o menos cada
uno de ellos trabaja al mismo ritmo así
que tenemos 2400 minutos
y los vamos a dividir entre 8 las 8
personas y esto nos va a dar 2400 entre
8 es igual a 300 minutos muy bien ya
tenemos la respuesta pero ojo nos están
pidiendo que el resultado lo digamos en
horas no en minutos como sabemos que
cada hora tiene 60 minutos ahora lo que
vamos a hacer es poner los 300 minutos
en este caso voy a escribir min para
minuto lo vamos a dividir entre 60
minutos por hora
qué son los minutos que tiene una hora y
esto va a ser igual 300 entre 60 es
igual a 5 y estas cinco son horas
y muy bien
hemos calculado el tiempo que le tomará
a ocho personas preparar las mil 200
bolsas de muestras de productos
hasta luego